I like falafel Phil you know like Judd
Judd Apatow the other day apologize for
his he goes sorry for making you so
cereal on pineapple Express
he said that in legitimate to you yeah
but not in a joking way like you really
apologized and I just want to tell white
people that you guys that [ __ ] I'm fine
with it
yeah I mean you can call me goofy boy
Magoo just as long as I'm in a movie
long as you're the lead
I mean you know it's a little different
when it's like Mickey Rooney in
Breakfast at Tiffany's robbing the
Chinese landlord yeah that's that's
another John when yo John Wade played
Genghis Khan in the Conklin David
Carradine played no first of all there's
an orange I thought that he was Asian
because he the way he died yeah yeah the
erotic asphyxiation covers all races oh
it does oh did that agents are super
into that I don't know what's the have
you guys into this you are so you're
into you like you and Bobby chokes he
drinks dude why he doesn't like choking
me but he's not that way he's very
gentle yeah yeah let's just kind of
finger my butt once did you say do you
happen to have a finger that's more dick
shape I did not say that day because I
don't like a finger look I will tell you
I will tell you that he always comments
on how exceptionally long my fingers are
so maybe he dates me because I have
bigger than normal
get some suppressed homosexual
hey what's your name let me see your
hands oh you're good what are you doing
Thursday night yeah so wait so why what
is the sensation with the choking
because I get girls and they asked me to
choke them I'm like okay to be honest
with you it's [ __ ] it's sort of
primal in a sense where before you
credit knocks you off of the other
senses
yeah nuts arse out to my arms getting
tired like you know what I mean they say
I can't quite figure out if it's more of
the domination same thing that gets me
off or if it's the actual act of being
excessive fixated yeah but whatever it
is it does it does you know cuz Bobby
and I are of a time where we've watched
that become popular over the years
didn't used to be like it wasn't a thing
no it wasn't the thing joking wasn't it
when you did that when you choked they
would call somebody oh you get arrested
Oh in this Danny yeah choke me are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah yeah I mean at
the misty
[Music]